[موسيقى]
من الخبر ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه
عبد الرحمن العصيمي يسعد صباحك عبد الرحمن
اهلا بك نتعرف معك على سيد الاطباق الجريش
تفضل غير المغشوش
صباح الخير سهام طبعا انا يعني في حاله
عذاب من الصباح صراحه لانه الريحه
والاجواء هنا جميله جدا صراحه مع الشيخ
طبعا منصور اسماعيل وهو شيف سعودي طبعا
مشاهد الان الجريش همم الشيخ منصور جالس
يجهز الان على النار وهنعرف الان همم وزي
ما انتم شايفين هذا الجريش وسيد الاطباق
فعلا في السعوديه ولا تخلو مائده في
السعوديه سواء في مناسبات الرسميه في
مناسبات الاعياد ايضا في مناسبات حتى
منزليه طبقه جريش حاضر بقوه
ويعتبر جزء لا يتجزا من الثقافه المطبخ
همم السعودي صباح الخير يا شيخ منصور
الشتويه هذا هو وقت جديد
طيب خليه يتكلم اول شيء خطوه وزاره
الثقافه مبادره روايات الاطباق الوطنيه
واعتماد الجريش طبق وطني انت كشف سعودي
كيف شايف هذه الخطوه طبعا هذه الخطوه
جميله جدا وجايه بعدها ان شاء الله باذن
الله خطوات ثانيه برضه من هيئه الطهاره
وزاره الثقافه في توثيق اكثر من طبق في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ولكن اليوم خطبه
الجريش لان اليوم فعليا شو هو السيد
الاطباق يعني اليوم نقول جميع الاطباق في
المناسبات في العزائم في جميع
كافه المناسبات العائليه في السعوديه تقدر
اطباق كلها متحركه والجيش ثابت سواء كان
الجيش الابيض النجدي او الجيش الاحمر
زي ما انتم شايفين همم جريش احمر
والجريش الابيض الجريش الاحمر
من همم في الاساس لان اليوم الاساس
بالجريش هو والجريش الابيض اللي هو الجريش
الجديد اللي هو يتسوى باللبن وانتقلت هذه
الثقافه من نجد الى المنطقه الشرقيه صار
يض زيها بطماط صار يضاف عليها الكشنه وصار
في تعديل بسيط في الجريش في المنطقه
الشرقيه
من جميع انحاء العالم العربي ومن العالم
كله خليني اشرح لهم ايش الجديد يعني يمكن
احد يتابعنا غير سعودي ما يفهم الطبقه
ومكوناته قمح هي حبه القمح الكامله تجرش
هذا هو وتتحول الى الجريش كانت تجرش قديما
بالراحه القديمه القديمه
الاكثر شعبيه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والاقدم تاريخيا لذلك ووثق اول طبقه اللي
هو طبق الجريش وزي ما قلنا انه ما في سفره
تخلو منه اصلا ياخذ وقت بالطبخ ياخذ وقت
وياخذ تكنيك ودائما الواحد ايش يقول لك
يقول لك والله بيت فلان جريشهم احلى من
بيت فلان كل واحد يتفاخر بين العوائل وبين
الناس مين اطعم جريش ومين افضل جريش جريشه
زين معناه الاكل لبيتهم كلها طيب
يحتاج وقت لانه المكونات واحده لكن مش الي
يفرق الان النفس والتكنيك فكان الامهات
الاقدام وكلهم يعني كانوا يتفاخرون طبق
جريش مين الذ ومين اجمل وليد فنان كان
يتفنن بالكشنه اللي فوق مع الليمون الاسود
ومع المسمنه بالضبط الكشن اللي فوق هذا
اللي لونه بني او اسود ايه الليمون الاسود
وعلى البصل تتكشن وتنحط فوق الجريش طبعا
يحلوا الجريش فيها وتعطيه نكهه اجمل سواء
كان احمر او سواء كان جريش ابيض فان البصل
اللي فوق هو شيء اساسي
من البقر هنا مساله اختياريه ولكن ضروري
وجود السمن عليه وشيء لا يمكن ان يتغير
يعني لا يمكن يستبدل الجريش بزيت الزيتون
او باي تعديل لازم تحافظ على الموروث
الشعبي
السهام الزملاء في دبي
فالجريش طبعا حاجه عظيمه جدا
يا عبد الرحمن
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله انت اي واحد تفضل
الاسمر ولا الابيض يا عبد الرحمن
الابيض
فانا تعودت على الابيض لكن الاحمر في
المنطقه الشرقيه في الحسى وما حواليها
برده مشهور جدا
وشي ثابت ايضا على الاطباق المناسبات صحيح
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الرحمن شكرا للشاف من
الخبر مراسل صباح العربيه عبد الرحمن والف
صحه عليك